hallo liebe freunde von easy german ich
bin kari und ich beantworte wird wieder
eure fragen und kommentare
salina wollten schreibt zu unserer
letzten episode ihr erinnert euch wir
waren bei der konferenz afrika neu
denken
salina schreibt es war eine gute folge
danke sarina ich wusste nicht bzw ich
kannte nicht einige der afrikanischen
kolonien ist es einfach für einen
afrikaner nach deutschland einzuwandern
ja salina die antwort ist ganz einfach
afrikaner können nicht einfach nach
deutschland einwandern und dass es auch
ein großes problem wenn nicht eines der
größten probleme in deutsch und
europäisch afrikanischem verhältnis ja
wir kennen das selber denn wir
organisieren seit vielen jahren
internationale jugendcamps und
austausche und das problem ist immer
wieder vorhanden
deutsche können ohne probleme in jedes
afrikanische land reisen manchmal muss
man ein visum beantragen aber es ist
nicht wirklich kompliziert hingegen
können afrikaner nicht einfach nach
deutschland kommen sie müssen visa
beantragen das dauert meistens sehr
lange ist es sehr kompliziert und ganz
oft werden die wiese auch einfach aus
irgendwelchen gründen abgelehnt
und da geht es darum ja worum geht s was
wollen die aus afrikanischen bzw was
wollen die europäischen länder und was
will deutschland sie haben natürlich
angst vor irregulärer migration und da
muss man sehen dass diese angst so
dominant ist dass sie auch das ganze
verhältnis die ganze partnerschaft
kaputt macht man redet immer von einem
dialog auf augenhöhe
aber wie kann man einen dialog auf
augenhöhe führen wenn wir überall
hinfahren können wo wir wollen und
afrikaner eben nicht zu uns kommen
können
marek schreibt zu der gleichen folge
kari kannst du bitte sagen was afrika
neu denken für dich bedeutet ja maric
was afrika neu denken für mich bedeutet
hat schon ein bisschen damit zu tun was
ich gerade zu der anderen frage gesagt
habe ich denke wir sollten vielmehr auf
augenhöhe und in einer
gleichberechtigten partnerschaft
miteinander arbeiten und da spreche ich
natürlich vor allem
für die perspektive und die blickweise
von europa ich kenne natürlich ein
bisschen die deutsche politik ich weiß
wie sie handeln und in der deutschen
politik wird immer ganz viel davon
gesagt wir sollen auf augenhöhe arbeiten
wir sollen partnerschaftliche arbeiten
aber de facto ist das eben nicht so
wir selber reisen seit vielen jahren
immer wieder in verschiedenen
afrikanischen länder ich war schon in
vielen verschiedenen ländern
und man muss sagen es gibt noch viele
von diesen alten strukturen zwar gibt es
heute keinen kolonialismus mehr aber die
entwicklungshilfe oder die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist in vielen
fällen ähnlich aufgebaut also nicht
ähnlich wie der kolonialismus aber er
ist ähnlich man kann sagen er bestärkt
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse es gibt immer
geld aus dem einen land oder aus dem ein
kontinent das ist in diesem fall europa
und afrika erscheint immer in einem
negativen bild als bittsteller und ich
denke wenn wir wirklich etwas ändern
wollen müssen vor allem auch die
europäischen regierungen damit anfangen
afrika tatsächlich als chance zu
begreifen und nicht nur als problem
kontinent und wir müssen auch
dementsprechend handeln es kann nicht
sein dass wir eine partnerschaft wollen
aber das ist unmöglich ist für afrikaner
nach europa zu reisen
ja und ich denke dass es afrika neu
denken für mich ein appell an europa zu
sagen lasst uns wirklich auf
partnerschaftliche augenhöhe arbeiten
shadow walker ford ifri sagt hallo kari
ich möchte fragen wie lesbian gay
bisexual transgender leute in
deutschland behandelt werden ich habe
gehört dass sie dort besser akzeptiert
sind ja stärker besser akzeptiert ist
natürlich immer die frage der
perspektive
besser akzeptiert im vergleich zu gehen
wenn du natürlich aus einem land oder
von einem kontinent kommst wo ja
menschen die nicht heterosexuell sind
schlecht behandelt werde
was leider in vielen teilen der welt der
fall ist dann kann man vielleicht sagen
in deutschland geht es diesen leuten
besser tatsächlich ist man in
deutschland relativ fortgeschrittenen
schon wenn man sich die geschichte
anguckt was die rechte für nicht
heterosexuelle menschen angeht das heißt
auf der straße ist das völlig normal
dass man transsexuelle bisexuelle und
homosexuelle menschen sieht und das
sollte auch normal sein aber wenn man
sich anguckt was eine völlige
gleichstellung ist dann muss man leider
sagen dass es in deutschland noch nicht
der fall ist nur ein beispiel thema denn
die themen sind natürlich sehr
verschieden
aber in deutschland wird im moment sehr
viel über die ehe diskutiert und ob die
ehe wirklich allen menschen gleichmäßig
zugänglich sein soll und das ist in
deutschland noch nicht der fall zwar
gibt es in deutschland eine ehe für
homosexuelle menschen die heißt die
eingetragene lebenspartnerschaft
aber damit hat man nicht die gleichen
rechte die man auch in einer ehe hunt
warum ist das in deutschland noch nicht
weiter ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung also
natürlich weiß ich warum weil die
parteien die regierenden parteien vor
allem die cdu das ist die partei von
angela merkel
das sind die christ konservativen und
die sind vor allem dagegen und behindern
das dass es diese neuen rechte gibt es
gibt immer wieder umfragen und
bemühungen in deutschland eigentlich
zeigen die umfragen dass ein großteil
der bevölkerung dafür ist in diesem fall
homosexuellen menschen völlig gleich zu
stellen und ihnen die gleiche ehe zu
erlauben
wie jede sexuelle paare sie haben aber
es ist eben noch nicht umgesetzt wenn du
mich fragst ist das nur eine frage der
zeit und ich kann nur hoffen dass es so
schnell wie möglich passiert alexandra
garcia schreibt hallo kathi ich bin neun
jahre alt und ich liebe sie german ich
wohne in den usa hallo alex du hast uns
ja schon öfters geschrieben grüße an
dich an dieser stelle
alex schreibt ich habe eine frage ist
deutschland deutsch also deutsches
deutsch wie in deutschland gesprochen
und österreichisches deutsch lot
different ja alex das kann man so alge
meint gar nicht sagen denn das hängt
immer sehr davon ab wo und wie das
deutsch gesprochen wird
es gibt im allgemeinen das hochdeutsch
das überall gelernt und auch verstanden
wird und vielfach auch gesprochen wird
nämlich in den meisten großstädten
darüber hinaus gibt es aber regionale
dialekte die in deutschland und in
österreich sehr verschieden sind aber
natürlich auch noch mal in den
unterschiedlichen regionen in
deutschland und in österreich
verschieden sind
es kann also sein dass ich als deutsche
nach österreich fahren und in einer
großen stadt wie wien bin und entspreche
ich hochdeutsch und die leute antworten
mir mit einem kleinen dialekt wir
verstehen uns perfekt es kann aber auch
genauso gut sein dass ich in ein kleines
dorf fahren oder in eine andere stadt in
österreich und ich verstehe nichts
absolut gar nichts obwohl die leute dort
auch deutsch sprechen
angelo enriquez schreibt hallöchen wie
begrüßen sich die deutschen hier in
mexiko gibt man einen kuss auf die wange
wenn zwei frauen sich begrüßen oder wenn
eine mann und ein frau wenn ein mann und
eine frau sich begrüßen
die männer geben sich die hand wie ist
das bei euch ja bei uns gibt es ganz
verschiedene formen
das ist ganz interessant es hängt auch
einmal ein bisschen von der jeweiligen
kultur der person ab grundsätzlich kann
man sagen dass man sich die hand gibt
wenn man sich nicht kennt wenn man sich
fremd ist wenn man sich zum ersten mal
sieht
wenn man sich hingegen schon lange kennt
dann gibt es verschiedene formen man
kann sich umarmen man kann sich trotzdem
die hand schütteln man kann auch einfach
einschlagen ja mal hier
gerd uwe faust das macht man zum
beispiel mit freunden aus spaß man kann
allerdings sich auch küsschen auf die
wange gegeben gibt es auch allerdings
ist das glaube ich nicht so populär in
deutschland wie im ausland
die letzte frage heute kommt von rap
dapd
keine ahnung tolles video liebe kari ich
habe auch eine frage wie gut können die
deutschen fremdsprachen sprechen gibt es
in deutschland eine fremdsprache außer
englisch
die man gerne lernt ja in deutschland
gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
fremdsprachen gelernt werden ich habe
mal für dich die wichtigsten
aufgeschrieben die in der schule
unterrichtet werden
englisch lernt eigentlich jeder
spätestens ab der fünften klasse
manchmal auch schon in den grundschulen
das heißt eigentlich hat jeder deutsche
mindestens sechs jahre englisch in der
schule meistens sogar 98 oder neun oder
mehr lehrer die zweite fremdsprache die
meistens unterrichtet wird ist
französisch dass es so die
zweitwichtigste sprache an vielen
schulen lernt man auch noch latein mehr
das alte latein das habe auch ich in der
schule gelernt und das ist so ein
bisschen tradition in deutschland dass
man das immer noch lernt und auch für
verschiedene bereiche benutzt dann noch
ganz populär ist spanisch ich glaube
spanisches mittlerweile sogar nach
englisch die populärste sprache in
deutschen schulen und auch ganz oft
unterrichtet ist italienisch was es dazu
noch gibt sind erstmal regionale
unterschiede so lernt man an den
verschiedenen grenzen in deutschland
auch immer die sprachen der
nachbarländer zum beispiel lernt man an
der niederländischen grenze
niederländisch ich habe zum beispiel
niederländisch in der schule gelernt an
der dänischen grenze hingegen also in
der gegend um flensburg lernt man
dänisch und an der polnischen grenze
also eine ostdeutschen ganze lärm und
polnisch auch in der schule und dann
wiederum gibt es noch ganz verrückte
schulen die noch andere sprachen
unterrichten wie zum beispiel russisch
chinesisch arabisch habe ich auch schon
alles gesehen das sind dann meistens
auch spezialschulen versprachen wo man
eben auch schon mit zwölf oder vierzehn
jahren solche fremdsprachen lernen kann
was ich zum beispiel in der schule
gelernt habe ich habe mit zehn jahren
angefangen englisch zu lernen
mit 12 13 latein
dann kam in der neuen klasse von
zwischen zu da war ich so 15 und dann
habe ich später auch noch niederländisch
angefangen das heißt ich habe vier
sprachen in der schule gelernt kann aber
leider nur zwei leute das war's auch
schon wieder für diese woche vielen dank
für all eure fragen
es tut mir leid dass ich nicht immer
alle beantworten kann aber schickt uns
unbedingt mehr
ja liebe leute das war's auch schon für
diese woche und zum schluss haben wir
noch zwei ankündigungen für euch als
erstes möchten uns noch mal bei euch
bedanken für eure unterstützung bei
pratt trion diese woche ganz speziellen
micro du bist unser patrick of the week
sozusagen
und wir haben eine besondere
überraschung für euch denn ab nächster
woche werden wir bei petri noch mehr
anbieten als bisher und zwar gibt es bei
patrick ab morgen sozusagen extra
material ihr wisst wir machen interviews
auf der straße wir sprechen mit vielen
leuten und wir zeigen euch immer nur
einen kleinen ausschnitt so die besten
antworten
aber natürlich haben wir dabei ganz viel
material was übrig ist und das geht
kriegt er nun auch als dankeschön bei
chin
vergesst nicht ihr seid schon ab einem
dollar dabei wenn ihr uns einen dollar
spendet bekommt ihr dafür auch von uns
etwas zurück wir sind euch wirklich
unglaublich dankbar denn dieses geld
ermöglicht tatsächlich unsere arbeit
bezahlt unsere studium miete unsere
ausrüstung und ohne euch kann über das
alles nicht schaffen also danke dafür
und wir möchten euch dieses extra
material als dankeschön dazugeben ab
morgen ja die zweite ankündigung geht
schon in die nächste woche nächste woche
ist klaus zu gast bei uns hierbei kari
antwortet wird klaus fragen beantworten
und jetzt kommt das special für euch der
klaus der ist nämlich geschichtslehrer
das heißt wenn ihr fragen habt zur
deutschen geschichte zum umgang mit der
deutschen geschichte zur nazi zeit zum
beispiel wie wird das ganze heute
gesehen was denken deutsche dann
schreibt uns diese fragen jetzt nächste
woche ein easy german car i antwortet
geschichts special mit klaus dabei also
schreibt uns eure fragen an den klaus
dankeschön fürs zuschauen in dieser
woche wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen
und bis zum nächsten mal